pendant l'opposition notre groupe sera
également dans l'opposition je viens de
vous le dire un groupe uni mais nous
posions responsable puis sur libre une
position indépendante pour servir
l'intérêt du pays voilà ce pourquoi nos
députés ont été élus dans des conditions
très difficiles en zone urbaine comme en
zone rurale je vais d'ailleurs les
remercier comme tous ceux qui ont été
candidats pour le premier tout ils ont
mené des combats utile avec de bonnes
équipes et nous allons avoir besoin
d'eux ceux qui ont été élus évidemment à
l'assemblée comme nous avons besoin de
nos sénateurs et ceux qui n'ont pas été
élus mais qui ont joué un rôle pour la
reconstruction du parti sauf que tout